one of the things I study in my lab is
called synesthesia and it represents a
blending of the senses so we've all
heard the word anesthesia which means no
feeling synesthesia means joined feeling
so somebody with synesthesia they might
hear music and it causes them to see
colors physically or they might hear
something and it puts a taste in their
mouth physically they're experiencing
that or they might eat something and it
puts a feeling on their fingertips the
most common forms of synesthesia have to
do with overlearn sequences like letters
or numbers or week days or months
triggering a color experience so
somebody might look at the number six
and that's read to that synesthete or
they look at the the letter J and that's
purple and it's an internal experience
it's automatic it's involuntary and it's
unconscious and to a synesthete it's
just self-evidently true that J is
purple and it used to be thought this
was very rare the original estimates for
one in 20,000 but we now know it's quite
common it's probably up to four percent
of the population has some form of
synesthesia there are many different
forms essentially any Cross blending of
the senses that you can think of my
colleagues and I have found a case
somewhere so so we now know it's very
common and the reason it's so
interesting to me is because it's a very
good inroad into understanding how
different brains can be can perceive
reality differently so you're sitting
here your neighbors sitting here and
you're both looking at the same thing
and yet you're seeing the world very
differently and it turns out synesthesia
is heritable so my lab is pulling the
genes for it right now
and and the reason that's so interesting
is because it's it's what I'm calling
perceptual genomics which is to say how
do little genetic changes change the way
we perceive reality so you know and of
course most synesthetes historically
have have lived their whole lives and
they may even die without ever
suspecting that they're seeing reality
differently than someone else because we
all accept the reality presented to us
so synesthesia is a really direct way to
look at how individual changes can lead
to different beliefs about reality